Well,
it's,
it is interesting that it never started
as a,
a pure business plan,
a 20 or 30 page business plan.
It really came about through
happenstance when I was taking a trip to
go to whistler ski week,
uh,
and I had booked the ticket,
the air flight on orbits and orbits did
not send me any information on the
destination.
And I'm a,
I'm very much a travel enthusiast.
I've traveled all my life having lived
or worked overseas,
uh,
on,
on many different occasions.
And I thought that it was strange that
there was no information provided by the
online travel agency.
So I actually decided to get into this
business initially by publishing a
series of online travel guides.
And we started out by partnering with an
airline America,
West Airlines with the thought of,
uh,
adding on additional partnerships over
time.
Eventually by stepping in a,
with the online guides that led to my
exploring other areas of opportunity in
the travel industry,
particularly with travel deals
publishing,
which really is our core business these
days.
Uh,
so we migrated from being a publisher of
pure online travel guides to being one
of being a rather large publisher of
travel deals today.
Uh,
Shermans travel.com
is a publisher of travel deals and
destination advice.
Uh,
we're very different from the Ota,
the online travel agencies like Expedia,
priceline,
and travelocity,
and Orbitz,
in fact,
many of those are our clients of ours,
uh,
but we are a pure publisher,
so we're advertising supported.
We published thousands of deals and
they're handpicked by our editors every
day and published on the website as well
as through our email products.
We have are a Sherman's top 25 travel
deals newsletter that comes out every
Wednesday,
uh,
that is received by over 4 million
subscribers.
Uh,
the website has a host of other
resources,
including over 300 travel guides,
videos,
one-on-ones,
slide shows,
a lot of great resources there.
Hotel reviews,
of course,
uh,
and a travel search tool.
Uh,
we also publish a magazine which is more
upscale while the website is more mass
market reaching the broad audience of
leisure travelers.
Uh,
the magazine's skews more upscale and
it's positioned around what we call
smart luxury.
So it's a combination of luxury but
still a good value.
And our brand positioning overall is
about value,
whether it's on the,
uh,
on the lower end,
what we call a smart bargain or the
higher end in terms of a smart luxury.
The magazine,
uh,
does cover some deals.
We have a section there called the Lux
list,
which is the,
uh,
the best values of the season that are
the best and foreign five star
vacations,
uh,
but the magazine is not necessarily
always looking for a deal per se.
The magazine will cover destinations and
talk about,
uh,
places to stay that are upscale but
still work but are worth the money.
Uh,
so we may talk about an $800 a night
resort in St Barts,
but at the same time we'll highlight one
that's three or $400.
That's less expensive.
It's still luxury,
but it's going to be a little more
affordable for what we view as a
significant portion of the population.
That is those,
uh,
that we call the mass affluent.
Not necessarily the ultra rich that are
willing to pay any price,
which may be point,
oh,
one percent of the population,
but rather a larger segment that want a
more affordable but still a luxurious
experience.
Well,
certainly anyone that is in the deals
business is in a good position these
days,
given the recession that we're in.
And that is true both on the high end in
terms of our luxury value positioning
with the magazine as well as for the
website and our email products that,
that,
uh,
provide great overall deals and
bargains.
Uh,
so we do find that a lot of suppliers
are price cutting.
There's no,
no doubt about that.
Hotels need to do that to fill up their
rooms and to decrease their vacancy
rates.
The same with the airlines.
Uh,
so it's a great time as a traveler to
find amazing deals out there.
Unfortunately for us as a business
though,
uh,
the suppliers and the agencies because
they're making less money means they
have less money to spend on advertising.
So the ad budgets,
uh,
have been,
certainly very tight this year,
uh,
in terms of hotspot vacations certainly
for American travelers.
Uh,
the Caribbean is doing incredibly well.
I think that may be because people have
been a little bit scared off of Mexico,
uh,
given uh,
the flu and then crime and some other
issues there.
So I know a number of travelers have
changed.
Plans have shifted perhaps to the
Caribbean.
Um,
in terms of other,
a hotspot,
certainly Americans are going to any
value destinations,
a London for example,
visit Britain's been doing an amazing
job in promoting London as a
destination.
It's always been relatively low cost to
get to in terms of the airfare,
but now the hotels are quite affordable
as well.
There's been a lot of price competition
there.
Uh,
there are also great values in terms of
sort of second tier destinations,
places like a Buddha,
budapest,
for example,
or even Luganda,
some other destinations in central and
eastern Europe that are very affordable
for travelers these days.